for more than ten thousand years the
average global temperature didn't change
by more than one degree celsius
but then humans started burning fossil
fuels
around here
global temperatures have risen about 1
degree celsius since pre-industrial
times
this is what that looks like so far
storms have gotten more intense
wildfires are more common
and ancient glaciers are melting faster
and faster
and that's just one degree of warming
without global action
the world is on track to warm at least 3
degrees celsius by
2100 this would be catastrophic
that's why most scientists agree that we
need to limit global warming to
this range between 1.5 and 2 degrees
celsius
carbon dioxide which is emitted when we
burn fossil fuels
accounts for most of the world's
greenhouse gas emissions
it's the main culprit behind climate
change
and to limit global warming to the
degree that scientists are calling for
we have to stop releasing it we have to
decarbonize
the us doesn't currently emit the most
carbon dioxide of any country
but as one of the oldest industrial
powers it's emitted more carbon dioxide
in total than any other country or
region so america has a big role to play
in decarbonizing but how is the u.s
supposed to do that
and is it actually possible
if you want to get halfway there by 2030
you have to start
now now going fast there is literally
zero more time to waste dave writes
about energy and climate for vox
and he says the 2020 u.s election comes
with fairly clear stakes
if trump is re-elected that's it like
there's
no chance for 1.5 and probably all
chances for two degrees
are gone the united states will withdraw
from the paris climate accord open up
the coal mines
new offshore oil and gas leasing
program president trump doesn't have a
climate policy
and his re-election will most likely
continue policies designed to boost the
fossil fuel industry
they'd increase carbon emissions instead
of decreasing them
and the effects would be felt globally
you just can't have
the world's second biggest economy
opting out
moving the opposite direction and expect
the world to get there
the other major candidate in the
election does have a plan to address
climate change and this part in
particular
is ambitious by 2050 the united states
will be
100 clean energy economy
biden has been convinced and pushed
to the point that he's got a great
climate plan
what biden's plan doesn't get into are
the details on how exactly the u.s would
actually do that
but there are people who have thought
about what it might look like to
decarbonize by 2050
and to understand that it helps to get a
picture of where america's energy comes
from
and where it goes sorry my son nearly
stepped on a snake
do you want to say hi this is saul
griffith he's a physicist
and an engineer but this is how dave
describes him probably the person who
knows more about energy
as it's used in the united states than
any other human being
a few years ago saul decided to make a
model of america's energy use
he ended up reading basically every
available piece of data from the energy
information administration department of
transportation
national highway transit authority
census bureau of labor statistics and
noaa
and so we pull all of those together to
build a very comprehensive picture of
the
u.s energy economy that picture of the
u.s energy economy
it looks like this
if you're just looking at the whole
thing at once it just looks like a big
pile of spaghetti it's hard to make
sense of but it just
traces energy every unit of energy
how does it enter the economy how is it
used
throughout the economy this kind of
chart is called a sankey diagram
and it's easier to understand in three
sections
these columns here on the left are the
sources of all the energy used in the
u.s
like natural gas coal solar
wind nuclear and oil
this column in the middle is what those
energy sources get converted into
so a lot of it becomes electricity most
oil becomes the fuel we use for
transportation
and here you can see how much natural
gas energy is being used to generate
electricity
versus being used directly to power
things like cooking stoves
and over here on the right this is where
all the energy is
used broken down into incredible detail
like how much energy is being used to
light shopping malls in the u.s
or how much energy is being used by
vehicles driven for work
so you start to get this incredibly
detailed picture of all of the
interconnections
which is really really important when
you do the next exercise but what
happens if we decarbonize
remember that carbon emissions come from
the burning of fossil fuels
this stuff and saul says that means that
to decarbonize
we just need to follow their path
the first place that leads you is here
with electricity
and the energy we use to generate it the
majority of which in the u.s
comes from two kinds of fossil fuel
natural gas
and coal if the us wants to decarbonize
it needs to stop getting electricity
this way
and to replace it with other
decarbonized energy sources
that means coal power plants gone gas
power plants
gone all electricity would come from
renewable sources
wind solar geothermal hydroelectric and
biomass
or nuclear energy decarbonizing the way
we get electricity would be
a huge investment but it would also only
eliminate 20 percent of emissions
and that's because electricity and
energy are not exactly the same thing
that doesn't solve the vehicle's
emissions it doesn't solve your your
heating emissions from using natural gas
or
fuel oil in your basement all these
other parts of the economy
draw their energy directly from fossil
fuels
like transportation we use oil for fuel
and commercial and residential buildings
where we use gas and oil for heat
but saul says there's a kind of elegant
solution to this
you decarbonize these sectors by
switching their energy source from here
to here make all of it
electric because we already have almost
all the technology we need to do it heat
pumps batteries electric vehicles
wind turbines nuclear power plants as we
know that that can work
we know we can do electric cars we know
we can do electric heat for nearly
everything
it's all in the end just about machines
right we got a bunch of machines that
use fossil fuel energy
we need to replace them with machines
that use clean electricity
and so it really just comes down to a
matter of industrial capacity how fast
can you build machines
there are some things we'd have a harder
time decarbonizing
air travel will rely on fossil fuels
until alternative technologies get
better
and things like steel and concrete are
really hard to manufacture without
fossil fuels
but if we decarbonized as much as
possible with the technology that we
have now
it would end most of the us's carbon
emissions
this church shows the country's carbon
emissions broken down by economic sector
if electricity residential commercial
and transportation
were mostly decarbonized you'd have
solved a lot of the problem
all of this would be a huge undertaking
and it needs to happen fast
saul's research modeled different
scenarios for the transition from fossil
fuel-based machines to
electric ones from a market-driven
transition
to carbon taxes to a much more direct
and heavy-handed approach
that would replace our machines with
their electric counterparts very quickly
and he found that because we've delayed
action for so long
none of these slower approaches will be
enough if you went back to
2000 and started then you could just put
like a
modest carbon tax in place and it would
have just eased us down over the course
of 30 years or whatever
but emissions kept rising and rising and
rising so now to get where we need to go
they gotta
fall off a cliff and that means zero
delay
we're just talking about a level of
industrial mobilization that none of us
alive have seen it would look like what
fdr did to prepare the us for war
literally every single solitary fossil
fuel machine that goes out of service
is replaced by a clean energy
alternative
every furnace car you know
factory name it nearly everyone is
buying an electric vehicle nearly
everyone is buying
rooftop solar nearly every new power
plant that comes online
is industrial scale solar or industrial
wind
we need that level of effort to do a lot
better than two degrees
all of recorded human history has
happened within an era of relative
climate stability
an era that's about to end
but we still have control over what
comes next
and the global effort that'll require
hinges in part on
what the us decides to do
america can decarbonize we have the
technology to do it
we have the resources the only question
is
whether we want to do it i have a 6 year
old and 11 year old and i have to
believe that's going to happen
otherwise and i have to try to make that
happen
as far as long as possible because it's
their future we're stealing by not doing
it
thanks for watching this episode of our
2020 election series
we're focusing on the issues that matter
most to you and we got this topic
requested by a lot of people
zach said the candidates should be
talking about the steps we need to take
to drastically reduce our carbon
footprint
and our impact on the environment jade
asked what policies will be implemented
during their terms to stop america from
being the second largest carbon producer
and oliver asked how do they plan to
reduce carbon emissions to zero and on
what timeline
we want to know what you think the
candidates should be talking about tell
us
at vox.com forward slash election videos